smoke
rose gently in the distance as debris
and men bobbed up and down in the waves
before disappearing entirely
great metal husks scattered the seabed
admiral togo was in an elated mood as he
stood on the bridge of his battle
scarred flagship
mikasa gazing across sparkling waters
to where japanese flags rose slowly
above the five remaining russian
warships
surrender togo had used nelson's classic
plan of attack
crossing the t and annihilated the enemy
it was over the russian fleet was no
more
it was the 28th of may 1905.
[Music]
days later togo visited the sasebo naval
hospital on kyushu island
to meet the defeated russian admiral
rajitzvinsky
recovering from a near-fatal head wound
roshitzvinsky rose weekly
and the two men exchanged a warm
handshake
togo quietly added defeat
is a common fate of a soldier there is
nothing to be ashamed of in it
the great point is whether we have
performed our duty
at the battle of tsushima the imperial
japanese navy's fitter
stronger leaner and better trained fleet
lost three
tiny torpedo boats russia
forfeited virtually its entire navy
450 tons of shipping to 126
thousand perhaps one of the most
significant naval battles in history
it was the grand finale of the
russo-japanese war of 1904-1905
a conflict of two empires over colonial
influence in china
korea and manchuria in its wake japanese
power in the east was cemented the seeds
of polish and finnish independence were
watered
and the first russian revolution
overthrew the sars
autocratic rule indeed the war set off a
chain of events
that led directly to world war one and
the communist revolution
of 1917
yet togo heihachiro was born into a land
of sword-wielding samurai feudal clans
and subsistence farmers
without banks factories warships foreign
relations
even wheeled vehicles japan was yet to
become a unified nation
new and ever-increasing contact with the
west since 1853 had caused a chain
reaction
that utterly transformed the nation
dragging a dizzy japan into the 19th
century world order
this is the story of that journey
one of the most astonishing and
unexpected half centuries of change and
revolution
in human history this
is the story of the rise
of an empire
[Music]
this documentary is sponsored by
magellan tv the documentary streaming
service
big thanks to magellan tv for their
continued support and voices of the past
we've got some fantastic documentaries
coming in 2021
because of their continued faith in the
channel got one word
pirates people do you like pirates
oh okay she likes pirates
magellan of course has a huge range of
documentaries as well more than
3 000 a great series to try that matches
up well with japan and the west is japan
from above 4k
a beautiful high quality exploration of
the incredible landscapes japan has to
offer
almost as good as visiting magellan is
essentially a netflix for documentaries
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30
off an annual membership this gives you
an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description
to claim your discounted membership
today thanks
commodore perry's arrival in the 1850s
provided the favorable opportunity
for reform people actually set eyes on
foreigners and heard them speak
read western books and translations
increasingly broadened their horizons
and then woke up to the fact that the
government could be overthrown by human
powers
metaphorically this was somewhat like a
death and blind man suddenly hearing
sounds and seeing colors for the first
time
[Music]
a great and mysterious event occurred
religious talismans
came fluttering down out of the empty
sky
men dressed as women women dressed as
men townspeople dancing through villages
villages convorting in towns whole
populations drunk
all geastic behavior in the streets and
paper talismans
falling from the heavens like cherry
blossoms
in the wind this world was coming to an
end a new one was at hand agenaica
what the hell sang the revelers bring it
on
it was the autumn of 1867.
eight years had passed since japan had
suddenly plugged into
the international economy destabilizing
government disrupting society sparking
violence and exponentially upending
external demand for products and
resources
the economy buckled prices soared many
became rich but many more
sunk into poverty as bullion left the
country in exchange for ships
guns and foreign curios a rural
population unused to the massive
overseas demand for their produce
struggled to keep up with supply famines
followed
urban riots and peasant uprisings swept
the country
japan was ripe for revolution
all rebellion was put down until over
huge swathes of the country
paper prayer talismans started falling
like snowflakes
from the sky ushering in the end of days
up and down the land the pent-up tension
of ordinary folk
suddenly ignited they took to the
streets singing and dancing
the final refrain was always air janaeka
what the hell why not who cares
a new age was coming
a few months later on january the 27th
1868
while the people continued their
bacchanalia the first clash of the civil
war
that would usher in that new age was
fought
fifteen thousand shogunal troops faced
five thousand rebels
from the southwestern clans of satsuma
and choshu
the shogun's men armed mainly with
spears advanced
and were repelled easily massacred by
howitzers and gatling guns
western weaponry tearing the old order
to shreds
on the second day they attacked again
but this time the rebels revealed a far
more powerful weapon a banner with the
imperial chrysanthemum symbol
emblazoned upon it the shogun's forces
melted away and the shogun himself fled
on a u.s warship to have fired on the
banner
would have been high treason
though my body may decay on the island
of ezo
my spirit guards my lord in the east
hijikata toshizo the shogun's last
general
carefully brush wrote his death poem on
june 20
1869 minutes before he had stood on the
ramparts of hakodate castle
in hokkaido no tenshukaku bastian
towered above this star-shaped
gun strewn french-style edifice it
was a european castle on a japanese
island
below in the bay circled a host of great
black ships
just like those that had forced japan to
open to the west in 1854
only this time it was the new imperial
government
the rebels of last year that sailed
these smoke belching leviathans
after the initial defeat at fushimi the
brutal civil war which had brought
hijikata here
had raged across the land sword-wielding
samurais had charged gatling guns
ancient matchlock aquabuses faced
cutting-edge rifles
and graceful castles defended by
handmade wooden cannon
were cremated by the latest british-made
artillery
after the first conflict in more than
200 years
the very fabric of this ancient land lay
in tatters
engulfed in the flames of modern warfare
hijikata himself had just bid farewell
to his french friends
brave men who had fought to the end with
him for a now hopeless cause
a decade ago it had been a criminal
offence to associate with a foreigner
let alone fight alongside one
this was the last stand there was
nowhere left to run
hijikata mounted his horse and rode out
with his men
they charged they died
it was june 20th 1869 and the new
imperial government was finally
victorious his imperial majesty was back
in his rightful place atop the land of
the gods
lifted there atop a wave of western
weaponry
the war and previous decade of turmoil
had made
one thing clear the world would never be
the same again
japan could no longer stand rigid
against the hurricane of change
but like a tree must bend and adapt to
thrive
in new conditions the newly sovereign
emperor meiji instructed his people
knowledge shall be sought throughout the
world
so as to strengthen the foundation of
imperial rule
[Music]
knelt and kept her head to the floor in
his ra bow
not daring to raise her eyes in front of
her
was a hanging screen and behind that she
supposed
was empress shoken a lady's voice rang
out bidding ume and the other four girls
to go to the usa and study for the good
of our country women in seconds it was
over
the lady in waiting ushered them out
heads low
eyes to the floor the girls were the
first ever japanese females to be sent
to study
abroad ume was just six
she was the youngest member of one of
the most ambitious groups of travellers
in history the iwakura embassy
a two-year global mission of diplomacy
investigation
observation and learning from 1871
to 1873. dispatching the iwakura mission
to america and europe
must be cited as the most important
event that built the foundation of our
state
in 1871 the new nation forged from
hundreds of thiefs and domains
was in dire straits held in
semi-colonial perjury by unequal
treaties
signed under threat of war most
importantly custom duties were
controlled externally
and japan had lost the ability to
protect domestic industries
or limit imports and exports
this was a national humiliation on top
of this unbearable shame
the new goods technologies in industrial
infrastructure so badly needed to fight
against the treaties and strengthen the
nation
all came from abroad at huge cost and
foreign experts had to be hired at great
expense
the solution send the ruling class on a
world
tour to discover the essence of a modern
nation state
and at the same time attempt to persuade
the western powers
to repeal the crippling treaties
[Music]
the global odyssey had started in san
francisco where crowds of up to fifty
thousand welcomed the diplomats
and gorped
reverend horatio stebbins at a banquet
of welcome
loudly proclaimed it seems a repetition
of the old story
where the magi of the east will led to
where the child lay
welcome most illustrious descendants of
the old stock
your presence is more welcome than the
frankincense and myrrh
the japanese envoys were akin to ancient
sages
come to worship at the fount of western
civilization
the usa less than a century old and
recovering from debilitating civil war
was honored to be the first port of call
for the globe-trotting entourage
and these enigmatic japanese tourists
kept
meticulous records of their journey
[Music]
customs and character in the east and
west are very different indeed at times
they seem to be direct opposites
westerners enjoy social activities and
public events eastern peoples tend to
avoid them
this is not only a relic of japan's
policy of national isolation
eastern people are also indifferent to
wealth and do not regard commerce as a
primary concern
westerners like to go out and enjoy
themselves socially eastern people on
the other hand
prefer to stay indoors and relax
creating gardens within their own homes
westerners stress practical science and
the rationality of material things
whereas eastern people emphasize the
science of the abstract
and non-material
eventually the explorers left the us for
britain and ume was left to be brought
up as an american lady
in new england she would later become a
pioneer
of women's education
[Music]
and so it was december the 5th 1872
when a young ito hirobumi future first
prime minister of japan
entered the surprisingly small but
intricately decorated audience chamber
at windsor castle
a fire burned with gusto but the room
still felt chilly
queen victoria the ruler of the world's
largest empire but modest of stature and
sour faced
was wrapped in great black fur trimmed
robes which all but hid the simple chair
on which she held state the ambassador
iwakura tomomi
looking resplendent in morning dress his
top hat
tucked under his arm bowed from the
waist
for someone who had only recently
forsaken his traditional kyoto court
robes for western clothing he played his
part
admirably well ito interpreted as the
queen bade iwakura welcome
and passed her greetings to his emperor
the ambassador
in turn extended the respects of his
sovereign and expressed the wish for
eternal friendship
between the two island realms the
audience
was brief and ended with victoria's wish
that the course of japanese policy may
be such as to ensure for the future
the lively sympathy of the nations of
christendom
with japan less ancient magi of the east
than the potential enemy at the gate
behave or else
next was a grand tour of europe followed
by a return home through the shiny new
suez canal
with stops at european colonies in asia
they had truly
seen the world though their request for
new treaties
had been rebuffed at every turn
but they did return home with something
just as important
they had set eyes on what they were up
against
[Music]
a modern state needed legitimacy among
the people the rule of law
railways public schools shipping lines
industrialized agriculture
banks stock exchanges telegraph a civil
code
a civil service police prisons lunatic
asylums a state postal service
sewage systems hospitals public
libraries and national anthem even
well-educated women to raise the next
generation
but most of all it needed strong armed
forces
international respect and a constitution
no more would the western world be held
at arm's length and looked down upon
the barbarians were now figures of
respect
to be emulated many japanese people even
looked down on themselves
as in the words of fukuzawa yukichi one
of the greatest thinkers of the day
half civilized japan had to climb
civilization's ladder attain
enlightenment status
or as fukuzawa would have it leave asia
and join europe they
were determined not to end as just
another
european colony japan would take the
best from around the world
and plant it at home though
some foreign seeds had already found
their way in
and were changing the country in
unexpected ways
[Music]
thomas glover sat in the corner of his
safe house sipping his chochu spirit
and watched as the fugitives he was
hiding debated
among themselves the authorities would
never raid the house of a foreigner it
was the ideal place for them to hide
the spectacle really demanded a more
contemplative tipple a good beer
but beer culture had not arrived in
nagasaki
yet glover was a criminal
a gun runner the men gesturing in front
of him were representatives of the two
most
powerful southern clans the satsuma and
choshu
they were negotiating a top-secret
alliance that much he knew
but he could not understand a word they
said so they tolerated his presence
he after all was the one who supplied
the guns
at the end of it the satsuma and choshu
clan's foes for hundreds of years
were allies their bitter enmity was
overcome by one great purpose
a burning desire to topple the shogun
which they duly did
with glover's help he had supplied
the rebels with modern ordnance rifles
and warships from europe
and in the new japan now found himself
in an enviable position
his influence with the country's new
rulers had won him the contract to
import japan's first mint
as well as a host of ships and other
industrial paraphernalia
and his role as a dealer of ships
brought him to the attention of iwasaki
yataro the owner of a fledgling startup
shipping business
called mitsubishi 14 years later in 1888
his input not to mention his government
friends had propelled mitsubishi to the
head
of japan's industrial race
glover was filthy rich glover
liked beer
[Music]
and a few years previously as japan's
only brewery looked set to go bust
he had stepped in to save it and add it
to mitsubishi's ever-growing portfolio
his japanese partners had been uncertain
but he had persuaded them
if japanese consumers were to drink this
strange bitter brew
it needed a japanese name and kirin a
kind of mythical dragon was settled upon
kirin is now one of the world's largest
brewers
and beer is japan's favorite alcoholic
drink
but beer was far from the only change
in the national taste buds
the japanese abominate meat eating for
on no account whatsoever will they eat
donkey
horse cow much less pig duck or hens
and they are naturally averse to lard
they regard a householder who slaughters
an animal reared in his house
as cruel and unclean
snow fell lightly as the group of ten
ontake monks
dressed in white from head to toe
approached the bridge over the imperial
palace's wide moat
they marched sharply up to the imperial
guards and demanded an
immediate audience with the emperor
when the soldiers refused they tried to
force their way in
the troops withdrew in formation raised
their rifles the monks charged
a volley rang out
four monks lay dead
bright red pooled around their white
cloud corpses
the polar opposite of the recently
adopted red-centered
hinomaru national flag
[Music]
these monks had given their lives to
tell the emperor that by consuming
animal flesh he was destroying the soul
of the japanese people
for japan a country that had been
largely vegetarian for 1200 years
was now embracing the taste of
civilization
beef and the emperor was leading the way
during the long years of limited
intercourse with other nations
meat-eating was known of chinese and
dutch merchants were permitted to engage
in the foul and in pure practice
and it was not unknown for the lower
classes of japanese society to do
likewise
but no civilized person would surely
contemplate such
self-defiling behavior until the meiji
revolution
turned everything on its head
there remained many people who blindly
dislike this saying that meat eating is
filthy in accordance with the customs
our nation has followed for many long
centuries
this is a specious argument borne out of
ignorant blindness that demonstrates a
lack of knowledge about the natural
disposition of human beings
and a failure to discern the principles
of the human body
meat eating was part of fukuzawa's
revolutionary crusade to civilize his
compatriots
an entire culture that believed eating
meat was to risk consuming
your own ancestors who might have been
reincarnated in animals
your own flesh and blood was urged to
embrace the practice
it seemed a ludicrous preposterous
notion but it quickly
came to pass beef is certainly a most
delicious thing isn't it
i wonder why we in japan haven't eaten
such a clean thing before
we should be grateful that even people
like ourselves can now eat beef
thanks to the fact that japan is
steadily becoming a truly
civilized country
[Music]
and meat consumption was just one
example of the massive
cultural changes of the meiji revolution
[Music]
during the last half of the 19th century
people who did not eat meat
suddenly did people who did not use
wheeled transport
suddenly did people who did not cut
their hair suddenly did people who had
painted their
teeth cosmetically black suddenly didn't
people who were traditionally written in
classical chinese
suddenly discovered literacy in the
vernacular even in previously disdained
european tongues
and perhaps most shocking at the time
some people rejected native gods and
prophets
in favor of a foreign deity the
christian
god finally same-sex love
once normal among men went underground
and female accession to the imperial
throne ceased
government food clothing culture change
was sweeping across the nation
at a dizzying pace but there was one
piece of the puzzle that would
eventually prove the most
consequential japan's ability
to make war
charles cooper penrose fitzgerald rear
admiral royal navy legally of the china
station
sat in his study overlooking the english
channel
and reflected on something that had been
bugging him for a while
the question of japan
as one of the first british visitors the
naval officer had seen it first in 1858
he'd eagerly snapped up delicate
porcelain and observed in astonishment
that shipping seemed little changed from
the 16th century
and yet on his last visit in 1897
he had found a country changed beyond
recognition
he wrote that he was quite certain they
are now a long way past the
imitative stage and in some matters they
appear
to have improved upon the methods of
their instructors
fitzgerald signed and reflected that an
excellent example of this
were the four giant armored cruisers
currently being built in newcastle
takiwa asama izumo iwate
were better designed than those built
for her majesty's navy
with rather more fighting power and
speed into a given tonnage
than has ever been done before
16th century military backwater to 20th
century military powerhouse
in four decades
initially japan had depended on the
imports of foreign weapons through
merchants like thomas glover
this had not been enough without an
indigenous munitions industry
foreign powers could easily hold the
country to ransom
in the event of war starting small a
basic industrial know-how was developed
through the 1870s and in 1880
the morata rifle was unveiled the model
going through various improvements as
the army became more sophisticated
and eventually being replaced by the
arisaka model in 1897
that would be used throughout the world
even by the royal navy in world war one
when british production fell short but
weapons were one thing tactics logistics
deployment strategy and the medical care
of military personnel
were quite another japan had introduced
conscription
in 1872 and several up-and-coming young
officers
had observed the franco-prussian war in
1870
they had seen the superior prussian
leadership weaponry
strategic thinking and use of modern
technology such as railways
and determined that the newly unified
germany was the best model for japan
so in 1885 responding to a formal
request from japan
helmuth von mulke chief of the imperial
german general staff
dispatched one of his most talented
officers jacob meckle
to tokyo
60 of japan's most senior officers were
returned to the classroom
they sat and took notes for a year as
their new sensei
lectured them in every aspect of
military science
he watched as they put theory into
practice drilling the officers time and
again
until everything was perfect then he
moved on to the army at large
reforming command supply communication
and medical units along
german lines new railways connecting
far-flung bases were engineered
even uniforms were henceforth to follow
the teutonic
model finally he looked at a map and
seeing the korean peninsula's location
declared that it was a knife pointing at
japan's belly
should korea fall into the hands of an
enemy power russia or china for example
japan would be at their mercy this
strategic observation led to the first
sino-japanese war
and the russo-japanese war both fought
over control
of the korean peninsula
and then there was the navy
the first three built-to-order naval
ships were completed in britain in 1878
and sailed to yokohama by british crews
the japanese did not feel that their own
sailors were competent enough
for the job during the next two decades
most japanese naval vessels were
constructed abroad
but increasingly they were supervised by
japanese personnel
and by the end of the century japan was
building better ships in english
shipyards
than england herself is constructing for
her own navy
by world war one japanese industry no
longer needed to outsource manufacturing
it was quite capable of building
world-class military vessels
on its own and indeed the first ever
airborne assault
from the sea was launched against german
and austro-hungarian shipping
in china on the 6th of september 1914
the student truly had become the teacher
and so from the top down the steps to a
modern
western civilization were being
aggressively pursued
japan was leaving asia and moving
towards europe but not everyone
was happy
when i swing around shadows of yesterday
are not seen
dark road to go is a mountain pass
to death
to shiroesuke refused the blindfold
offered him climbed the ladder
and stood below the noose grinning at
those
gathered to watch him swing he
a gambler ruffian latter-day robin hood
was there for leading
thousands of desperate peasants in
rebellion
destroying debt and tax records
declaring freedom and self-government
and leading his followers to tokyo armed
with spears
farming gear and hunting muskets under a
banner proclaiming
new rule of benevolence it
had been a hopeless cause and he knew it
tashiro had bid a final farewell to his
family
before leaving to lead the furious
farmers who took their inspiration from
the new idea
of freedom and people's rights vague
foreign notions which were trickling
down even into rural valleys and
mountain communities
the government met them with gunfire
hundreds perhaps thousands had perished
now tashiro would join them
he stood unflinching as the rope was
placed around his neck
the board was kicked from beneath him
it was february the 19th 1885
at first after the tumultuous 60s in the
1870s the people mostly in the
countryside their lives unchanged
had listened to rumors of great
goings-on in the cities and ports
of men and women with strange coloured
skins and strange ways
of great ships and of long carriages
traveling on metal roads
new types of clothes and meat eating
they had in the main shrugged and got on
with the same job peasants had always
done
producing food and raising silkworms
then things started to change
first farmers were given far more
autonomy in what they could grow
then all commoners were ordered to take
a surname previously such things had
only been for the rich and powerful
not mere farmers then came the land
taxes peasants had always been tithed of
course a share of their crops more in
good years than bad
but this was a uniform three percent of
the land value
payable in cash most rural people had
never used money before
subsistence farmers had little to sell
and bought
even less there were widespread protests
some violent next
came the blood tax the government
came for their sons
they were told the boys would become
great warriors for the emperor but rumor
had it that their blood
was being fed to foreigners the peasant
backlash worsened and troops those very
same conscript boys posted to far-off
prefectures
were time and again sent in to quell
disorder
gradually things calmed down in much of
the country the conscripts sent wages
home to pay taxes
the government lowered the rate to 2.5
percent the first peasant-led
cooperatives enabled a degree of
self-help and development
and the social change that had swept the
cities slowly
in patchwork fashion spread to the
countryside in the form of schools
post offices and police very
occasionally a foreigner
a teacher or perhaps engineer carved in
uncomfortable
unpractical looking clothing with
armor-like black footwear and topped off
with hilarious headgear popped up some
of the more dapper and wealthier
villages started to return from trips to
town with
leather shoes and bowler hats
the countryside was never fully pacified
however and rising debts extortionate
rents combined with a little knowledge
and consciousness of basic western
liberal thought
led to a freedom and people's rights
movement for which
tashiro isuke among others gave his life
but the real challenge was from the
samurai
[Music]
as a cast of hereditary warriors they
were unsuited to a world where commerce
industry
and european learning ruled the roost
first they lost their right to wear
swords in public
then their stipends switched to
government bonds
many samurai tried to adapt but failed
miserably
sinking into abject poverty
people they still regarded as deeply
inferior
prospered one thing they did know how to
do was fight
an old-school samurai in government such
as saigo takamori
tried to persuade his colleagues that a
good old-fashioned invasion of
defenseless korea
was just what was needed most of the
government fresh back from their
globetrotting mission disagreed knowing
full well that the western powers not to
mention china
would swiftly punish japan the would-be
invaders
resigned and returned to their rural
homes between 1873
and 1877 time and time again they rose
up in arms
but all the revolts ended in failure
the end came on september the 24th 1877
when saigon and his 25 000 insurgents
after eight months of fighting were
reduced to just 40 men
performed sepuku and the last rebels
charged
to their death
peasant conscripts had bested the mighty
samurai
modernity was victorious the old ways
were truly done
[Music]
future conflicts would mostly be fought
by opposing factions and political
parties
in newspapers public meetings and
demonstrations
the western concept of politics and
widespread public participation
in politics had been superimposed upon
all the practices of local governance
and slowly a party system of government
would develop
but there was a feeling that the decade
of giddy change
needed to be reined in there could be no
going back but the way forward
should be more considered accepting
foreign ways unthinkingly
became a thing of the past from now on
japanese spirit western learning
wakon yosai was the way
at the custom house we were attended to
by minute officials in blue
uniforms of european pattern and leather
boots
very civil creatures contrasting
pleasantly with the insolent and
rapacious officials
who performed the same duties at new
york
isabella byrd a pioneering female
british journalist
the upright and devout daughter of a
most victorian of victorian vickers
was one of a growing number of
westerners who were fascinated by japan
and knew that her readers would be
equally so
but by 1878 tokyo kyoto and the
central regions were already old hat her
audience needed the titillation
of a path less traveled she
went north
alone but for an interpreter against the
strong advice of the government
she pushed on through recently
war-ravaged lands
where new japan had hardly ventured as
far as the lately colonized island
of hokkaido where the intrepid
adventurer lived with what some claimed
were a lost caucasian or jewish tribe
the indigenous
ainu people her fans
loved it
[Music]
japan was new exotic the dream of
centuries of legends realized and was
already drawing not only merchants like
glover eager to make a quick buck
but writers and critics who spread
knowledge and familiarity
around the world other europeans and
americans settled down
and while few embraced all the practices
and cultures of their adopted land
one custom tended to appeal
the charm of the japanese system of hot
bathing
is proved by the fact that almost all
the foreign residents in the country
adopt it europeans and americans were
not yet fully persuaded of the wisdom of
daily bathing
abarth a week if that was more than
sufficient
japan was a revelation every country
house has its bathtub
in which the body can be purified and
reinvigorated
after the toils of the day they lay back
and unwound but baths weren't the only
fashion
to catch on internationally
george frederick ernest albert who would
in a distant future rule the british
empire as george v
lay slumped in an armchair in 1881
his right hand holding a book his left
arm
being pricked with little instruments
that look like camel hair brushes
only instead of hairs they consist of so
many very minute
needles he was engaging in what was
becoming something akin to a rite of
passage
for british royals the souvenir tattoo
the artist hori cheo first sketches the
outline on the skin
then pricks in the colors required blue
or red holding the instrument in the
right hand and grasping your arm with
the left
we did not find the pricking hurt at all
and where the royal family led mere
mortals
followed tattoos in japan were
and are the mark of ruffians at best
mobsters
at worst the government was horrified
and forbade the practice
the prince of wales later edward viii
wrote in 1922
my chief disappointment is not being
able to get tattooed in japan
but it seems it's been made illegal
though i can't think why
from the 1860s onwards lacquerware fans
and ceramics with japanese scenes upon
them
became the height of fashion around the
world this was part of a movement
known as japanism painting architecture
landscaping ceramics and
fashion fed eagerly on a fresh aesthetic
which swiftly became incorporated and
eventually one of the foundations of
20th century
art those inspired include van gogh
monet matisse
renoir and picasso so you see how
quickly things can change
these days one would not look twice at a
japanese walking around
amsterdam in a black suit and high hat
while our beauties with their
night dresses and high heels could
patter to tokyo
without drawing any of the attention or
the admiration they valued
and indeed kimono was certainly worn as
party pieces and
indoor wear extensively in the late 19th
century
and the wearing of high heels did indeed
take off among
women leaving open the possibility the
japanese footwear
could have inspired this still popular
western craze
and the passion for western clothing
exploded even more quickly in japan
first soldiers and police then postmen
then dapper gentlemen of means and style
and just very occasionally a lady
attending a western-style ball
or events where foreigners were present
then there were the swimsuit girls
pictures of whom were sold for domestic
consumption but also snapped up
voraciously
by overseas visitors by the end of the
century
western clothing was no longer novel it
had taken root as deeply
as railways and beef
clothing aesthetics ideas techniques
habits all crisscrossed from east to
west and from west to east
and amongst all this tooing and throwing
as have been the way
since the beginnings of international
trade people
were a valued commodity
[Music]
matsue ortana was in a state of extreme
excitement
she was about to escape this hell hole
her lover segokichi was coming for her
outside the australian outback landscape
was a never-ending expanse of red-brown
soil and scraggy low bushes
a far cry from her lush green kyushu
home
[Music]
inside the festering room was a stained
sleeping mat
and a suitcase with her few possessions
matsue was 21 and had been sold into
prostitution
and she was there in the australian
desert with the full approval of the
government
who believed that should asian gold rush
immigrants not have olive skinned women
to buy sex from
they would ravage respectable white
ladies instead
matsue was as far as the australians
were concerned
a pressure valve to protect anglo-saxon
society her poverty-stricken parents
had sold her to pay a tax bill
matsue was not alone there were tens of
thousands just like her throughout the
world
thanks to better diet and medical care
the japanese population had increased at
a huge speed
and many of the excess population were
encouraged to try their luck
abroad fukuzawa yukichi even argued that
because the vast majority of immigrants
were single men
for the encouragement of overseas
settlement by our people it is necessary
for prostitutes
to go abroad matsue was shot
by her lover as she was packing to
escape the brothel
he then took his own life the police
investigated but no motive was found
case closed
anyone who is the least bit japanese
must try to advance japan from the third
rank
where she now stands to the second and
when she achieves the second rank
then to the first and finally to the
foremost position
in the entire world
it was early in the morning but viscount
maury aronori
was already in full dress uniform ready
to leave
for the palace outside the streets
bubbled with excitement
the townsfolk got up in their finest and
brightest garb
was celebrating with music and chanting
dragging
huge wheeled shrines through the streets
so their neighborhood gods could join in
the festivities
today february the 11th 1889
was the crowning glory of maury's life
and that
of most of those celebrating so freely
outside
an imperial constitution was to be
granted
to the people
the constitution was a unique charter
comprising
european legal and governmental
philosophy with the best of japanese
morals and spirit
mori allowed himself a minute to
contemplate the course his life had
taken
he had come a long way as a young man he
had studied in britain and europe
been japan's first ambassador to the usa
he'd also joined the brotherhood of the
new life
a new york utopian community shoveling
manure and butchering swine on the
brotherhood's farm
had built muscles and helped instilled a
lifelong belief
in personal physical strength
now he was minister for education
looking at europe or america we see that
in every nation people of all classes
both men and women alike possess a love
of country
and an unshakable national unity
the population should be taught to the
very marrow of their bones to feel a
fervent spirit of loyalty
and patriotism to maintain a
steadfastness of character and constancy
of purpose
to be ashamed of cowardice and to hold
all sevility
in contempt the people
needed to be physically strong and
literate and devoted
to their emperor all children rich
and poor now had elementary education
focused on discipline friendship and
obedience
maury's secretary knocked softly on his
study door
there was a young man to see him would
he grant an audience
maury needed to gather his thoughts
before leaving for the palace he
declined
shortly after the vikant walked
gracefully down his grand staircase
he could see the young man excited and
clearly refusing to leave
suddenly the youth lunged at him and
thrust a concealed kitchen knife into
maury's belly
the nobleman fell and through a mist of
pain and confusion
saw his bodyguard cut the rogue down
maury aronori one of the greatest
statesmen of his age
died of the wound a scrap of paper found
on the assailant
said that this was the punishment for
his insulting the great shrine of issei
and the emperor the knife was little
different to that
which he had used to slaughter pigs in
new york
the constitution soon led to treaty
revision one more
rung of the ladder though maurice
was not the only assassination attempt
[Music]
nicholas alexandrovich heir to the
russian throne
sat back in his rickshaw it had been a
beautiful trip to lake biwa and now they
were returning to kyoto through the
narrow streets of otsu
funny things these rickshaws he thought
looking undignified but actually highly
comfortable and great fun
if only his fresh tattoo wasn't so
painful he regretted it already
he rubbed his arm gently as he caught
the eye of a young japanese girl
standing in the crowd around the
rickshaw her jet black hair
shimmering in the light suddenly
out of nowhere a blade slashed down
blood spurted from his face and he
recoiled
the attacker fled two rickshaw drivers
following hot on his heels
tackling him to the ground nicholas was
taken swiftly for treatment
by morning the emperor major himself
fearing a pretext for russia to declare
war
was at the wounded prince's bedside
having sped through the night by train
from tokyo then there was uproar
ten thousand telegrams were sent by
well-wishers and a young girl in kyoto
slit her throat to demonstrate remorse
russia did not declare war and the
policeman who would attack nicholas was
given life imprisonment
despite the government urging the death
penalty the japanese judiciary had come
of age
and was demonstrating its independence
and the rule of law
over political expediency but
by the end of the century a fresh
pushback against what many saw as the
depredations of foreigners and
destruction of japanese ways
was reaching extreme levels cracks had
appeared as far back as 1886
a major example being the sinking of the
british merchant ship the normanton
that year the crew had been a mix of
british german indian and chinese
sailors with 25 japanese passengers
aboard
the captain in european crew had hogged
the lifeboats
and left the asians to their fate not
one
had survived the japanese public had
been outraged
a song caught on across the nation no
matter how different your race may be
no matter how little you know of mercy
you just stood by and watched
you left us there to die you cowered
in the years since nationalist
gatherings of tens of thousands
demanding action against the foreign
powers
and their expulsion from asian colonies
had become frequent events
they went so far as to protect nurture
and fund asian revolutionaries
such as sunni atsen a man who later
became china's
first president the government treading
a fine line
used victory in the sino-japanese war of
1895
overseas expansion and the imposition of
unfair treaties with korea to control
nationalist tendencies and keep
sentiment behind it
but by the time admiral togo was
preparing his ships for imminent combat
with russia
nakay chomin another great thinker of
the age noted that
if we beat russia we expand to the
continent and bring peace to asia
if we lose our people will awaken
from their dream peace to asia
meant a pax nipponicus
an asia under japanese tutelage but
nikai believed that losing to russia
would mean the whole japanese
enlightenment
a revolution largely imposed from above
would disintegrate as nakaya predicted
the victory once more carried the people
with their government
and as japanese power grew inevitably
voices in the west
started to sound the alarm
starting in germany use of words like
yellow peril
soon spread to the usa japan had ceased
to be a quaint
feminine-like exotic realm of dainty
post-feudal vistas
it was now a nation on an equal footing
crucially non-christian and non-white
a threat to widespread cherished ideas
of the supremacy of the white race
and superiority of christian
civilization
hawkish politicians dreamed of a time
when she could be put
in her place the japanese
were only too aware of this and felt
those insults
keenly for now though they would grin
and bear it bide their time and hope to
establish
true acceptance as equals in the coming
decades
this thinking and the lack of that
acceptance
was also to shape the century
to come
ito hirobumi now marquis ito stood in
the grand magnificence of the grafton
gallery
in mayfair london before the movers and
shakers of british society
and thanked his thousand guests for
their warm welcome
to queen victoria's diamond jubilee
his journey had been japan's journey
from humble interpreter for the iroquois
embassy
to the heady heights of the first rank
of nations it
was 1897 and japan and ito felt
confident and wealthy enough to be
lavish in its entertainment to win the
hearts and minds of the leaders
of the most powerful empire on earth
there was a feeling that the recent
abolition of the unequal treaties might
develop into a grand alliance between
the two island empires
an anglo-japanese alliance if so
japan would have reached the very peak
of the international order
in only four decades
[Music]
the triumphs had been small at first ito
grinned to himself when he thought of
the innocents
the passengers on the first railway had
removed their shoes before entering the
carriages
and embarrassed on a lighting to realize
their mistake
and yet these days japanese-owned
railways were expanding
even overseas and now japan manufactured
and exported
her own locomotives back then the post
office had been the first japanese
government body to achieve international
standards
by 1882 4 000 post offices and over 3
000
miles of telegraph extended swift
communications
into even the most isolated regions
by the 1880s an industrial base had been
firmly established and export markets
particularly in silk were developing
well
now at the turn of the century the
majority of his guests
in london were dressed in that luxury
fabric
the global silk market now belonged to
japan
ito thought back to his long
conversations with the german chancellor
von bismarck
who would argue that small countries
such as japan should rely
on their own efforts not on
international law or
diplomatic agreements to maintain their
independence against the encroaching of
imperialist powers
like france and britain consequently
against the arguments of many
military strength was at the heart of
the new state
the army trained in german fashion had
shocked the world with swift victory
over china
two years previously the navy formed
under british tutelage
was already world class territory had
grown exponentially too
first northwards to hokkaido and the
islands that the russians knew as the
kirills
then south to the ryukyu kingdom now
okinawa prefecture
taiwan had been seeded by china as a
spoil of war
strictly controlled and regulated
elections were also regularly held
political parties social movements and
civil society
now formed the bedrock of many
communities
japan ito felt now had no need
to escape from asia rather the buds of a
new asia
were just starting to blossom in the
fertile soil
of japanese islands
japan's was a unique asian modernity
distinct from a western one and it would
spread
marcus ito went back to his british
guests charming them effortlessly
after long years of dedicated practice
the anglo-japanese alliance
was signed in 1902
japan had made it onto the world stage
risen to mori aranori's foretold first
rank
[Music]
and just three years later the waters of
tsushima seethed with men
as russian battleships slipped slowly
sleekly
beneath the cresting waves
drenched blonde heads bobbed as comrades
struggle against each other
treading water wildly to stay afloat
they would not last long a night was
coming
minutes before mikasa admiral togo's
flagship had sustained huge damage and
many casualties under fire from the very
sailors drowning
before his eyes age 21 togo had been
there in 1869
at the beginning of the new age in the
black ships bombarding hakodate castle
as the final shogunate forces made their
futile
last stand his childhood friend mori
aranori had once
insisted upon japan's destiny amongst
the first rank of nations
and as togo looked across the bow of his
ship it seemed
at that moment to have truly advanced to
the heralded foremost position
it had taken less than 40 years
it was time to be magnanimous to show
that japan was an
honorable nation generous and humane in
victory
a worthy great power togo
ordered me casa's lifeboats out
an hour later the first of the sailors
many mere boys
huddled cross-legged on the heaving deck
blankets around them
holding mugs of steaming tea
in the distance another ship exploded
into flame
and sank in minutes the bones
of the russian bear were being laid to
rest
beneath the tsushima strait
in 1905 the russian war was won
and one of the most fascinating social
cultural and political transformations
of all history
had ended but the japanese journey
of the 20th century a journey set into
motion
50 years before by the great black ships
belching smoke
on the horizon that journey
had only just begun
you